all right let's jump into this first
story ladies and gentlemen in what may
be one of the most shocking revelations
from January 6 thus far
Julie Kelly who is just on this show
this past week says breaking drama and
the proud boys trial yesterday after FBI
agent caught lying on the stand and
concealing evidence from defense
attorneys not only that
the messages the long story short of it
this agent thought they were deleting
messages from their what was it called
the link system the link system yeah and
they were actually just putting them
like a hidden tab which the defense
found and were like wow you lied about
all this and there's even messages where
they say things like delete the I I've
been in order to destroy evidence this
one's really important one message says
an agent made a request to special agent
Miller to quote go into a a CHS
informant report that Miller just put
together an edit out that the agent was
present so hold on a minute this is a
January 6th seditious conspiracy case
for the proud boys and there was a
special agent there there was some kind
of federal agent present with these
people
oh that's it that's evidence of federal
involvement right there now here's the
crazy thing the story from Politico says
this assistant U.S attorney Jocelyn
Ballentine who is supervising the case
for the justice department acknowledged
the likely spill of classified
information Thursday morning she raised
particular concerns about a message sent
to Miller by another agent who works on
Covert activity
and who said she did not work on the
Proud boys case oh yeah I believe that
describing a supervisor's order to quote
destroy
338 items of evidence
it's a huge number of evidence
destroying any evidence listen
obstructed by my uh by my friends down
in Washington DC let you know that those
pieces of evidence were totally
immaterial you don't need to worry about
those 338 or the 400 excuse me 338
pieces of evidence that were destroyed
don't even ask any questions by the way
I love the fact that they wrote down
they wrote in an email oh by the way my
boss told me to destroy all this
evidence like if you're going to delete
your evidence
don't go ahead and you know write an
email to somebody about it if you're
gonna do something illegal don't tell
people you're doing it you know there's
a line in the wire of that and it's it's
Stringer Bell and he's like are you
taking notes on a criminal conspiracy
and grabs the notepad and tears it up
you know I I'm kind of worried that
we're sitting here all laughing having a
good old time meanwhile this is direct
evidence of the the utmost government
corruption the the reason I mean these
guys are being tortured how long has
this been going on I mean when we see
this kind of corruption when we see this
kind of definitely illegal activity of
destroying evidence how long has the
government been behaving this way has it
been the whole time is it only recently
I would assume probably the past hundred
years probably the whole Jekyll Island
and who was it uh I would assume Wilson
yeah I mean I think I mean Hamilton was
pretty nefarious it's like the
government would ever lie to us about
like you know something like a war at
this level but it's sort of shocking to
like continuously be made aware of the
fact that the government is yeah they
were founded by Jr Hoover no but it's
like at this level like to this level I
really think that it's something that's
probably come in the past 15 years like
this level this level yeah because
because of how much how much information
we all just openly put out on the
internet there's also been like how easy
it is to monitor us that's I think that
that this is fairly new there's probably
been the desire you you do have the FBI
wiretapping and stuff in in the past but
I think that it's probably 15 years has
really been you know since the Snowden
revolutions were ever Revelations were
what 10 years ago now I think so 10
years this year yeah you know 15 maybe
20 years there's been an increase I
think since Obama in like General level
of trusting the government too well so
so I I think it's I think it's a little
both because I do think there's a part
of it that's been going on from the
start but I I I think what's more
powerful now and and Elon has actually
been been talking about this is that now
we have the ability to share this
information and we have the ability to
talk about these things directly uh in
ways that like we can live tweet from
inside a federal courtroom about what's
going on and then that gets shared at
Mass scale because of Twitter and then
the people behind the scenes would have
to be able to respond to that versus you
know a cub reporter writing that up and
it goes in some local paper somewhere
now we have the ability with distributed
networks to actually be able to share it
very quickly number two
because of the Patriot Act and the high
level of technological sophistication
that that Snowden and others have been
able to to prove and and show to us and
people I used to work with at the fort
they become very stupid right so they're
they're extremely powerful but they
don't need to be sophisticated anymore
so you you get these dumb levels of
operations that never seem to go
anywhere or these stupid cover stories
like this nordstream 2 thing oh no it
was it was this Pro Ukrainian group and
they just expect everybody to run with
that because back in the day that's how
it used to work they would just hand
something to the New York Times New York
Times operation Mockingbird yeah the New
York Times would print it and then
everybody would just go off of that
because that's the paper of record
meanwhile nowadays you can be on Twitter
and actually go in and say wait a minute
like I know a guy in Denmark and he says
that he was near the pier the night that
that happened and this is what he saw
and so instead of this uh or post a
video of it or and post a video of it I
actually said that
the night of the bin Laden raid
um you can actually go back and find
that the most significant thing that
happened that night in 2011 wasn't
necessarily that the United States
government conducted a covert operation
okay that happens but it was that there
was a Pakistani guy excuse me um yeah no
Pakistan Pakistan guy down the street
live tweeting it yeah he said hey a
helicopter just flew over my house hey
there's guys getting out hey there's all
these explosions in gunfire what's going
on he's live tweeting yeah he's actually
live tweeting the bin Laden I I hope the
threat is still up somewhere live
tweeting the operation in real time I
said that's the future right there
that's the future because now I think it
was
what is it was Christopher Hitchens or
somebody uh said this recently um or you
know brought this up recently that he
said he said I don't read newspapers and
he said well why don't he read
newspapers well because I know people in
these various Industries and therefore I
get the information before the newspaper
that's Twitter that's social media well
yeah local news can become National in
seconds to uh to a to a certain degree
the federal government is attempting to
frame the proud voice I should say
they're literally trying to frame them
the seditious conspiracy thing is is
ridiculous wasn't there an agent who
said they didn't hear anything like this
or what was that about yeah there were
early on and I think this also came out
because Julie Kelly was reporting on it
on Twitter
um she's amazing yeah she's spectacular
and there were some documents um
right let's do it yes
um yeah so there were some documents
from the that she had posted where FBI
agents or whatever federal agents had
said that they were with the proud boys
and that they were like embedded with
them and that they heard absolutely no
evidence of pre-plan of January 6th at
all so and so they make the here's the
crazy and the FBI had also said that
there was no evidence of pre-planning
initially it was uh this guy Dominic
pizzola was charged with I think
trespassing parading and like vandalism
or something he broke a window he broke
a window well allegedly uh and because
he's not been convicted of anything and
then
um they came later like a year later and
added seditious conspiracy and I think
the reason they did that was because
they kept saying Insurrection over and
over again and everyone on the right
correctly pointed out yet nobody's been
charged with anything related to any
kind of insurrection and then all of a
sudden miraculously Enrique tario the
leader of the proud boys conspiracy
yeah and they're I think the only ones
if you do a search like you can who by
the way wasn't at January right yep
wasn't he in jail yeah he was I think so
that's so weird Federal customer and you
can look I mean the doj has all of the
case documents up on the website there's
like 944 cases and if you do searches
you can do searches for like assault
there aren't that many of them you know
and here's the issue right so here's the
issue to go back to because I saw some
people out there saying well these you
know these videos that Tucker put out
and this bid it doesn't change anything
because we've seen the other videos and
we've seen the committee and we all know
what happened that day here's what is
significant about those videos and and
we can talk a little bit about because I
do know something about
um the the larger tropho videos that
that is coming by the way
um that
of those what number you just said 944
944 people how many of them have
actually been charged with anything
violent anything seditious 10 about 10
maybe 10 yeah and so the other 90 of
this are people that were walking around
that were taking pictures Norm Macdonald
had that tweet up where he said the
violent terrorists are abiding by The
Velvet ropes and statues right yeah and
and and that's exactly right and so you
can be nuanced enough to be able to say
that yeah there were you know certain
amount what uh you know 75 people 100
people let's say that that did get out
of hand and there was hooliganism right
but the vast majority of people there it
was just a crazy situation people had
the doors left open people were escorted
in
jacobsley the big old book saying it
should be illegal to report this stuff
she also said it was orwellian God she
has this she has like the reverse
dictionary yeah so she doesn't
understand see I love I love when they
do stuff like this I took more of it
more I want more censorship of like
Goosebumps and Matilda
I want Whoopi Goldberg to just just 24
7. keep going like Keep Her On Air all
day long right because the thing you
showed me yesterday was Amber athe's
piece and spectator about politico's
banned words can we steal her too yeah
yeah that's funny Politico pregnant
persons yeah she's got a book she's got
it we're laughing as the problem's
getting worse yeah government corruption
anything to me that it keeps getting
worse even though everyone keeps
screaming louder well it's it's like the
whole like it's the squeeze because
there's people are starting to notice
like all this stuff had been moving this
in this direction had been really kind
of under the radar until kovid kind of
brought it to the to kind of everyone
well between kovitz
outside in their kids classrooms
everyone saw it after the the massive
what do you always say hierarchy not
hypocrisy yeah it's hierarchy that after
after Floyd was killed you know it's
okay to go protest Against Racism but
otherwise
you can't protest the lockdowns but you
can protest recently they called on
those michiganders who protested in
Lansing racist for going to the Capitol
saying that they should get to open
their nail salon
they said racist and that's the that's
the thing people started to notice that
wait a minute there is nothing racist
about going to the store thanks for
watching this this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time